it's my first time here and it's just
the the best combination of like green
and big city and great public
transportation and cool bars and
actually really excellent food so
obviously the the best way to get to a
conference is to speak at it and I would
encourage pretty much anyone who even
thinks they have an idea to a submitter
a CFP you know it's just a great
opportunity to meet like the coolest
people doing the coolest programming
language and I don't think there's a way
you could regret it it's just been you
know nothing but fun and learning and a
you know community that that sense of
like we're all in this together
really enjoy about jas kana it's
fantastic all the speakers are great got
a lot of friends who also came here so
just like people i know from from other
conferences and other other states other
countries it's it's a it's a great
gathering spot I think really fun my
biggest takeaway is probably that the
community is so massive and so large and
so friendly still there's so many people
to meet but everyone's really
approachable everyone's really friendly
no one feels like oh I've been here
before so I'm veteran I don't need to
talk to the new people there they really
feel like they'll guide you along if you
don't know what you're doing or they'll
sit down and talk with you and discuss
any type of topic that you're really
interested in um I love everything about
the conference so my first time here was
actually last year one of I got at
Pickett's it was sponsored by Google
because they were trying to support more
women in tech and I love the community
here I love the warm welcome that I got
I love that people helped me out to
actually come to the conference and this
year I started thinking okay what do i
do to also come to the conference and if
work out so I'm super happy to be here
Dana's coffee you has been really
amazing this is the first european
conference I've been to actually I've
only been to one's in the United States
before this of course the day has come
family in general is incredible and
today's come to you is no exception to
that
Oh
you